mad boy Entertainment Tonight Canada
we're in Canada I'm from Toronto I love
Jonathan so six months of the year it's
amazing the other six whatever it's
still like everybody's friendlier in
nicer than than in New York we try to
get the same so so dearly on behalf of
Toronto if I can do that have you any
time I was just there I was just
visiting a month ago oh nice so I mean
Golden Globe nomination congratulations
thank you but what I'm really looking
for is the Toronto Film Critics Circle
that Golden Globe is was a real nice pat
on the back yeah does it do those
accusations still mean a lot and do they
still you still hold them in a high
regard so much I mean somewhere in my
mind I'm still just gonna be like that
fourth character on Dawson's Creek that
everybody made fun of so when when you
get good news I don't like I like to UM
wholeheartedly celebrate and appreciate
it and not let that moment and be lost
who around you gets the most excited and
shares that kind of excited definitely
my daughter yeah she goes nuts yeah
that's amazing if you had to share that
with her you know these these kind of
film in in in relation to the male ethic
that that kind of went around this film
for a short period of time um how does
that impact you differently as a female
because majority of the cast is males so
I wonder for yourself when you hear that
kind of stuff you're obviously
disappointed about the picture yeah and
wondering what's gonna happen that kind
of uncertainty but also as a female I'm
sure that kind of news impacts you
differently how did it affect you all
around I found it reach remote izing
yeah honestly I found that I mean I was
and as I have been with everyone who has
come forward with their stories and
their experiences as painful and as
personal as they are my heart went out
to the people who came forward in this
situation
and and I thought gosh here once again
it's all about the that's the tyranny of
abuse is that it's all about the abuser
it's always about them here we are in a
situation now where this movie which is
the result of so many people's love and
time and life's work is going to
basically be for naught and and that's
disheartening mm-hmm
and he was kind of a huge opportunity
for me to censor myself in a big movie
with him legendary director and worked
so hard and had just totally fallen for
everyone that I worked with we had such
a great working environment so
collaborative super creative
lots of trust and love and then poof
it's gone
overnight so that again it just sort of
reinforced it's like I get it it's a
man's world it's really just it's that's
what it is and so when this idea was
hatched that we were gonna go in and try
and rewrite history I was I was on the
front line I was like you can have my
salary you can just take it and I didn't
even do it for like that's not why I
work um
if that'll help you you can have it and
you can have my break and you can have
whatever like I'll just be there I'll
just be there waiting how impressed with
you how quickly you know talking really
how quickly he turned it around despite
the critics and actually this that is
like a subplot to this amazing film now
how quickly everyone bound together and
turned it over and now the film will
live and like that will kind of live in
its its own existence yeah it's so
interesting and I am the funny thing
about Ridley is he says you know people
say that I should say that it's hard but
it's not it's it's it's stressful and I
love stress like I live on it and I was
he was he was excited to try and pull
this off mm-hmm
it's a it was a great picture to last
seek last question here just um if money
was no object
would can you finish that sentence money
was no object I would if I had all the
money in the world sure I would pay for
everyone's college education